all right welcome everyone to the 7:30
class and in this class again we're
gonna continue to talk about the
Olympiad round number four which
happened today that was a very very big
matchup today USA versus India India is
very strong this year this Olympia
because they have Vishy Anand playing
for the team after 12-year absence so he
is definitely the strength but
unfortunately he is the one who lost
today against Fabiano Caruana
from st. Louis u.s. top player us number
one who is gonna play in the beginning
of November for the world championship
match against Magnus Carlsen so this is
a big game a lot of people were watching
this and probably world champion was
also keeping a close eye on it to see
how his opponent will do so Fabian open
up with d4 Knight of six c4 e6 and he
played the move g3 the Catalan okay this
is the Catalan okay so you have to know
this idea and he's been playing this
been experimenting with this he I
haven't seen him play before but this
year he's been doing this catalana had
some successes so d5 Bishop g2 normally
have the knight on f3 here but this is
playable so the point here he wants to
keep the knight on G one night check
Queen takes a 6 ok
and now so I want to give you a chance
here so how many of you saw this game
like do you remember the move he played
here the movie played here you do okay
let's don't say the move yet I want to
see if who can find or maybe even guess
the Fabiana so because I was like first
when I saw this move I was this really
really and then of course I clicked on a
database to see how many times this move
was played and there was no games found
so that immediately tell me that this
was a novelty a powerful novelty you
know that doesn't look like anything but
it worked out great for him here so
again don't raise your hand if you've
seen the game okay
so let's let others to to try to see
what is Fabiana car wanna play here to
surprise five-time world champion
it's it was pretty shocking when I saw
it before it's not shocking move it's
you know it's it's so no move I mean it
might not be a great move but it's it's
a decent proof okay Caleb Bishop III
look at that move good job Kelly
I mean you saw the game properly but
okay look at that move guys we are told
not to put a bishop on that square
usually right that is blockading the
pawn this is the mother in chess you
know you sit in front of the computer
long enough you can come up with ideas
or if you have a you know good team you
they're gonna bring you some ideas like
this to stop c5 it's very simple
stopping c5 if you play the c5 now he's
gonna say thank you very much for the
pawn and you're not getting the pawn
back here excuse me
no no no he's not planning to move the
bishop you're just planning to keep it
there for now
stop see five well just can you wait a
little bit yeah we'll get to that point
okay so Bishop III and I was curious
because I didn't watch the game live so
I watched afterwards I was like I was
curious how much time on spent here
because obviously when your encounter
with a move like this is a little bit of
a shock she spent about close to five
minutes here already for analysis a lot
I mean he's one of the the best prepared
game and he has a fantastic memory and
he can remember things and he knows so
much surprise never been played before
this moment novelty we call that so okay
I don't spend per five minutes you said
okay let me just develop the bishop now
queen drops back to c2 so there is no b5
temples or anything now it has us and
now comes the next surprise of the game
I'll give you another five guesses to
find the next month ah very good night
h3 huh that's interesting you guys think
about 9h Trudeau okay I guess the other
moves are more normal yeah Knight h3
putting the knight on the rim but he's
trying to go to a four what he's trying
to do he's trying to keep the light
square bishop diagonal open okay oh now
I checked again he's been about seven
minutes now here so of course you have
to Bishop III of who you're just
completely out of prep Amin who would be
like you really think about this so
probably glancing I think that what
happened was they were glancing through
the position and a computer on a high
depth was throwing this move Bishop III
and whenever you see unusual move like
this he's like is this really gonna work
because most of the time people don't
think about moves like this and then you
know he started to analyze or you know
his trainer and then
they realize this this works it's it's
it's something you would do for one game
I don't think you would see people
repeat this move I mean this is just
it's more like a surprise factor effect
you know play the big role this is I
don't think you're playing a move like
this in a world championship you know I
mean so but let's take a look we should
be six Quincy to nine h3e five since C
five doesn't work
an aunt wants to do something actually
if I maybe wasn't the best there was a
suggestion maybe to play with a knight
computer like 95 years so II five
these castles so you got an awkward
looking [ __ ] poetry awkward knight on
h3 but computer showing white is
slightly better I mean it's amazing yeah
it's like you play two moves that just
they don't look logical at all and there
shouldn't work according all the
principles but with the current
technology and a strong computers it's
just so dynamic that it just and it's
very hard for black because he's he
thinks he hasn't done anything wrong and
his opponent is playing quickly all
these moves and lots of pressure now on
Anand so h6 is played controlling the g5
squares and stopping some 95 ideas maybe
later on and now takes only five ninety
five ninety three developing
Queeny seven plate rock ad one normal
move rook e8 Knight f4 now the night is
getting ready to jump in on d5 create
some pressure so c6 is played preventing
that now what do you think what do you
think
Fabiana played here what is the plan in
this position for white to try to prove
he has he has an advantage Michael
Knight night a4 I don't you want to go
there but maybe like
he didn't play 94 maybe I can start to
play like 94 you know hitting your
Bishop Michael and then I have some even
g5 ideas kicking the night and pick up
only to some ideas okay but yet you have
to try to have a plan and you have to
understand where you should play here
where your strength is here so I have a
question for you where is the strength
here on the queenside for white or on
the kick side and there is a very simple
way to determine that if you think if
you know how to think about that you
very quickly realize kingside why is
kingside lots of pieces and that's what
I wanted to hear
pan majority don't always think about a
majority on a queen side we have a such
thing called as a king side majority as
well okay don't forget that four on
three you have on there you got four
pounds versus three and there is a king
size majority you're not going to push
everything but you can try to expand to
get the control of the center okay there
is a king side majority okay now
so but first things first
which piece needs to be improved here
very clearly this piece shouldn't be
here
ashish aha bishop if the bishop has only
three how are you gonna expand you're
never gonna be able to push your lip on
right so what you need to do first
bishop perfect now I don't probably got
you know little bit frustrated with this
position it's unusual and you know you
cannot develop the bishop here so he
decided to take a chance but it was a
very risky move g5 move that I would be
quite hesitant to play now it's
certainly weakening move but he wanted
to get his bishop into the game so
that's the reason you know actually a
computer thing it's not a bad move it's
just it's a little bit on a risky side
okay but it's not easy to move you don't
have a good move how to how or where to
develop your bishop so g5 93 play by
Fabiano takes and now how are you gonna
capture back question is
Aashish
doesn't look like you're certain about
your move your Adi
Caleb
Kohi takes I'm not sure can something on
that third-ranked okay lateral yeah you
want to take with the loop to have
options okay and don't you worry about
Bishop f5 because you have II for ideas
okay
well actually so he played Bishop e5
first to trade the strong bishop the
bishop on d4 is very strong now another
great move here played by Fabiano
rookie three Kenna I think it just I
have Queen c7
well actually I also have 94 Adi
hmm
you want to prepare the F for break okay
because the pawn on d5 is a target but
for that you need to improve one of your
pieces can and you just play like RoR
excellent
that's very nice good job Ken Bishop f5
now attacking the rook absolutely
Bishop g6 now Anand wants to play rook
e8 and after it manages to do it it
should be okay yeah but temple white has
the temple here and he's gonna use it f
for excellent like and here a nun makes
the blunder
it's like Ashley yeah it's basically
moved and lost in the game for a moment
I'm gonna flip the board and you were
playing with black here you will Anand
situation here white is still okay if
black plays correctly he is very
slightly worse but after the move in the
game he is pretty much lost I mean it's
it's hard to understand why but he just
gets made it or he loses material but I
will show you the line you think you're
trying to play the best move for black
that's why I flipped the board so you're
on the black side here what is the best
move or the best in the best
continuation here actually
this is correct but your second move is
not correct Queen takes e5 before I mean
see 536 rook 88 excellent that is the
correct move your rook is stuck on a 8
you need to bring this piece into the
game okay so he probably didn't like
this because of a 5 here but you know
it's it's not it's not so clear night h5
and things are a little bit loose here
Black's let's say take 23 capture
capture some rope d3 ideas you have okay
and black is getting some activity what
is your question when you can but when
you
okay go here this pawn is little bit
hanging
giving me this great square huh yeah
well f6 I take I think it was something
like this computer was showing block is
doing doing okay you know very slightly
worse so rou kd8 was the move I don't
sit let me take here first and when he
takes he was gonna take taking pero que
da but sometimes this little details you
know once you miss this little detail
now it's losing because of which idea
which huh which idea he overlooked here
or maybe underestimated how strong this
is
Bishop takes d4 Bishop takes Bishop
correct sorry I flipped the board back
Queen takes and now GF and now suddenly
you got a look coming to g3 you got f5
coming as well and Queen h6 you know all
the pieces are perfectly placed he goes
Quincy five check King h1 it's likely
that it was counting on maybe taking the
pawn on e4 because this rookie is still
remaining out of the game and now f5 is
very strong at five Luke g3 the queen h6
so and if he plays here that's what he
played sorry takes he took with the rock
if he takes with the bishop why is this
losing rajesh dink Caleb
absolutely queen g to check look at that
check and picking up that truck okay
picking up that rook excellent sir
simply rook takes e4 and now very nice
move by Fabiano of course not taking
bishop before check and blocking is in
trouble very nice move huh no you want
to trade the look that is not in a game
Adi you know this piece is not in the
game why you want to trade them might be
good again but what's the square for
this row guys so of course rook g3 now
you threaten to simply play f5 and then
Queen h6 comes in f5 is a huge threat so
not much iron can do so you played here
and after the next move he resigned
because he cannot stop against the
threat of f5 so what is the move that is
gonna who's the enforce the resignation
we see one trait
why are you trading Queens you have a
meeting attack you want to keep the
Queens Michael we have to tie up the
pieces
tie up blocks pieces well which one
looks more active
of course you three because you want to
play a5 and queen h6 Ashish it's not
even a question about that okay
you control the file you're pinning this
and you're threatening to play a five
that's this is very very strong okay and
winning the game yeah and now okay five
yeah yeah so here he resigned actually
because there is no way to avoid lose it
losing a piece here so King h7 f5 which
is just by Ashish rook takes f5 if you
take what the Queen I take it's
important to note that after the check
there's Queen g1 move that's a very
important move okay
and if I go rook t1 check you just
simply go back look f1 and now the queen
is under attack and white his upper
piece there should be a win all right so
that's why after Queen e3 he resigned I
mean at this point computer was showing
about two and a half point advantage for
Caruana so in Caruana one in the second
board we had Wesley slow drew
comfortably as black against Hari
Krishna both three he car and Nakamura
was very slightly better draw against
did it and board for was a relatively
quick draw
Sascha Kieran was white against Shanklin
but he didn't get anything so it was
Aberdeen so us is doing really well
no Carlsen actually not playing he
declined to play and is preparing for
the match against Caruana yeah yes he is
Armenia is doing quite well they want
all their matches as well let's focus
now guys black to play and win so black
is a very strong grandmaster last itsuka
from czech republic
how did grandma sell as Nika break
through here and win
Black has the advantage he has very
active pieces and black to play and win
yes active night strong pawn on d4 but
how to break break in win
yeah yeah have to have you have to have
a good follow-up yeah that's a hard one
so you have to calculate quite a few
moves here first you have to try to see
ideas or ideas are out there okay can
who eat ooh this six and if I play
you mean this move but if I pin you can
yeah
Caleb excellent by Caleb sacrificing the
night I know what did you see the
follow-up they recovered then he escapes
so the point is what Caleb is doing he's
trying to go to here to control the
escape square and now threatening check
here okay there are a lot of lines to
Caleb did you calculate everything
alright so first of all this one how you
win
check now if it goes here
you just take take check you win the
rook and if it goes here
check
taketake
pin it to win it and if it goes
backwards
taketake check winning the rock so
that's that's the line if he goes king
e2 now
let's take a look at the Queen f3
defense that way I'm stopping you from
playing the move rook f6 rookie 3
excellent now Queen f5 route D to e8
threatening rookie to check and this
seems to be winning because if he plays
rook t2 what do you have
and rookie one takes check
winning it the Queen looking for okay
good so that's what Queen f3 now what
are you doing after Queen f5 this is a
much tougher much tougher move to deal
with listing Isis think okay there are
ideas rook rook h1 is an idea for white
so you have to do things very quick and
important you have to do it strong
alright what's the idea here Michael
huh
oh yeah yeah but we are going T to what
is the idea guys you need to bring more
pieces into the game okay
no more pieces you need to bring
actively Caleb did really interesting
threatening a little rookie to check at
some point right and also using the idea
past pants meant to be pushed
now iterating check and taking the pawn
here excellent by the way he can play a
few things here so you can start with
Knight c3 but that loses to a fantastic
move here bringing more forces into the
attack ish
new powerful powerful play yes and you
threaten to play rook F for okay
mating perfect so it is rook takes d3
now this is losing how rook takes d3
Queen takes d3o rook have six check King
III Queen if I check checking this guy
and absolutely and that's the solution
okay so a lot of lines but I think you
win so you have to come up with the idea
to sacrifice on f2 then takes back you
have queen h7 sorry Queen h2 move
that's very ya activating the queen and
stopping okay okay white to play and win
this is the game mommy dr of versus
ponomaryov mommy dr of panama y if you
know anybody not a scam or not you've
seen it before okay then don't say it if
you seen it that's good
it's a rapid game by the way take your
time
well pickup on doesn't mean you're gonna
win here sir
we have to win a piece a sheesh
mmm Bishop takes e4
kingi five then I go rock d1 maybe some
chances here
huh
okay
okay
it's bit unexpected idea but it's very
nice neat idea you are winning Appy hint
for you you're winning a piece the three
move combination Michael Bishop d7 addy
guys you'll not don't allow Bishop d7
because then he blocks you what you
gonna do first
d7 of course Hoshi now he takes what but
you could say take that's was incorrect
King g7 draw Bishop a4 Michael yes check
King cannot come up because he takes so
he has to go here look p7 and look at
the important job the bishop doing here
covering the d1 square so mami dro wins
the piece and the game as well
wanna marry off yeah yeah alright so
let's do this again very direct approach
this one check takes check and you win
the game got it alright excellent job
guys
thank you for coming and we'll see you
next time
you
[Music]